[Music]
you know it's out of my hands i i got
hurt they drafted it they drafted lamar
in the first round um at some point
you know
either you know something was going to
happen between the two of us this is my
situation right now
and i'm gonna do my best to handle it
the right way it's our team
all of us together it's our team
i don't go out there and block you know
i don't go out there and catch the ball
i don't meet tackles
i just do my part because i love to
that was a great answer from lamar
jackson he was asked is it your team now
he said it's our team i love that and
that's great joe flacco just looks sad i
had forgotten how much he looked like
bert from sesame street we haven't seen
much of joe flacco recently and look he
started off the season strong i think
the drafting lamar jackson a little fire
under his butt little red hot poker
chris as you may say
and and something happened it kind of
tailed off and then he got hurt and and
i think the ravens have been waiting for
this moment because i think they have
lingering resentment toward flacco for
getting them over a barrel after super
bowl 47 and taking full advantage of his
situation and forcing them to overpay
him and then because they had to
structure the contract in a way that was
back loaded after three years he was
able to force them to overpay him again
so he has always been there to take as
much money as possible and look he's got
every right to do it but if you slip
you're gone and i think the ravens are
happy to say see you later joe flacco
and now the question becomes with lamar
jackson the starter what happens to joe
flacco but let's focus on jackson right
do you think jackson really is the
answer because we've talked a lot about
carson wentz the physicality the
propensity for injury we already have an
ankle injury for lamar jackson it's not
going to keep him from starting but are
you comfortable handing your offense to
a guy who is on pace if he was the
quarterback for the full season you have
a 1300 rushing yard yeah are you
comfortable with that kind of physical
risk i i am yes i mean hey you know what
you're drafting them for it you know so
i'm so i'm sick of hearing teams going
you know we drafted this guy because
he's a great athlete and then they never
actually run him or do anything to show
that he's a great athlete so this is
what it is he does a very good job and
you see in these highlights of avoiding
big hits for the most part it's
something he's very good at so yes he's
going to have some wear and tear but i
think ulta billy mike this is the
weather ravens want to pipe football
they want to beat you up they want to
pipe physical you know their drop back
passing game we're not gonna sit here
and be scared of that with joe flacco
and the weapons they have they're good
but they're nothing crazy there the
strength of their team is their big
offensive line their running game and
they have marty morningweg and added to
that greg roman greg roman the oc for
colin kaepernick out there with the
49ers when they were running rough shop
around football so that brings more
creativity to their offense that's why
lamar is the right guy
rough shop i don't know rough shop yeah
is that right
[Laughter]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports